my point is you know this business is
changing it really is I'll take Andrew
Schultz as an example yeah because he's
killing I'll take Matt Rife as an
example why you said his name and he
popped
but like you look at Andrew you look at
Matt Rife and they're there are people
that have Matt Rife has never had a
special on anywhere but YouTube yeah
Andrew Schultz has never had a special
if I'm not mistaken anywhere than
YouTube yeah
uh Andrew Schultz
all but does all his own booking all his
own podcast all his own everything he
does it all himself
to think that to think that
that you'll always be a necessity in
someone's life and I say this out loud
about my marriage
uh
Leanne and I Leanne and I have always
had a solid marriage
always but we neglected it for the past
you know when the girl I'll say when the
girl during the pandemic me touring me
doing the movie me going back on tour
the girls getting out of high school
George getting out of high school
getting into college Isla and we
neglected our marriage and and and not
bad like no one did anything deceitful
nothing no one hit anyone no one raised
their voice at anyone we just weren't
paying attention to like each other and
I'm telling you right now my wife has
made a
decision to start dating me again it's
it's it's it is the coolest thing that's
ever happened to our relationship is
that she has decided to start dating me
again and and and and and and listen I
have to be very 100 candid we're on I'm
on testosterone lian's on this thing I
don't know what the name of it is but
it's like good for ladies going through
menopause it helps like increase their
and and maybe it was all uh [__]
stuff going through your body but like
suffice to say that we're paying
attention to our relationship last night
we were in the hot tub until 11 o'clock
talking kissing unless yesterday
oh it's so good she texted me I hate it
she texted me the other day I was doing
a podcast with Bob mannery and she said
to me we had she said to me uh look what
you did
I don't know I just think it's so sweet
it's it's well it's it is I I gotta be
honest with you okay pal what are you
doing I didn't mean this this is the
craziest [__] podcast what about me
and my wife yeah what the [__] are you
doing right now no I'm loving it I'm
just saying I'm I'm crying because I'm
loving it when like two people are like
intentional and find their way back to
each other like me yeah and it's like
it's not like we were ever doing
anything disingenuous or living out of
Integrity we were just like just kind of
doing coexisting coexisting and like
having fun and still having sex like
every now and then but like
I was at doing Bob memories podcast and
I texted her I said I'm in this
Hollywood Pete can take my car back do
you want to get dinner and
this will make me emotional because it's
such a badass [__] move
she texted me she said just get a hotel
room let's get room service and
we I was like
I was with one of the most beautiful
women in the world at the time Charlotte
McKinney I was standing with I'm
standing next to her when I got that
text
that woman was [__] invisible to me
and my dick was getting hard and I was
like my [__] wife just tickled me
from across the hill and goes and I was
like [__] yeah and I went to that hotel
room proud I went to the sunset Tower I
went to the guy up front I said I need a
hotel room for the night and and he
recognized me I didn't realize what I'm
saying and he's like huh I said my wife
just texted me this [__] awesome text
and he's like I'm a big fan I know who
Leanne is are you [__] serious and I
was like she's coming over right now and
it was like the coolest [__] but this is
my point of in saying this right this is
my point in saying this
Hollywood has to understand
that right now we're co-existing all of
us are kind of doing our own [__]
I mean this respectfully
but like you and Santino could forewall
these theaters and our in our agents and
managers understand this because for all
these theaters
do the same deal deals are changing
people are making overall deals with
with with with tour with uh with with uh
promoters deals are changing
everything's changing everything's
moving forward
and to think that anyone in this [__]
world is going to pay attention to a
Goddamn thermostat
from 10 [__] years ago longer 15. 15
years ago they need to understand they
need to understand that those two those
people need to go to dinner and work
their [__] out because we'll we'll skate
past them in a heartbeat yeah in a
heartbeat yeah we do we will not amen I
will not I will not come I'll tell you
this I want everyone that I work with to
understand I will not compliment my my
relationship with Bobby Lee my
relationship my personal relationship
for anyone's ongoing beef that is my
relationship with him is my relationship
with him and it's same with Andrew
Schultz
same with Joe Rogan you know no one
[__] with Joe Rogan like this
it's it's insane everyone needs to
understand that they they should that
that we are we are a team like us Comics
we're our friends we hang out with each
other we're like brothers we all grew up
together look I I only exist
tigerbelly only exists bad friends only
exists is because
you exist because Sakura exists Rogan
exists amen Whitney Cummings amen amen
only if without you guys I would we
would just be a small little thing that
nobody would listen to but because of
the family Vibe well I have to say this
I have to say this only and I mean it's
for real Bobby you are an amazing talent
you are an amazing talent you have a you
have a team around you that is
undeniable yeah but but and so like and
Joe but that I pay that comment for you
like something's burning was only able
to come back because you were my first
guest and and we got two million views
out the gate and everyone's like how do
we get all something's burning yeah so
like we all scratch each other's back
and help each other out and and it's
it's insane to me to think that there
would be someone in this business that
thinks they're more important than the
talent that they could that they could
they could get in between friendships
and negotiate friendships or allow
friends to get it's that's just a little
crazy to me
you know we're like I'll tell you right
now that [__] doesn't happen with Rogan
I don't know I've never given Rogan's a
number to a soul yeah no one I get you
get you get uh publicist and they're
like we got a lot of big plans we got a
lot of big plans when are you getting
unbroken yeah and you're like yeah but
he's done Corleone he's The Godfather
you know no one [__] with him
you know yeah he's also he doesn't need
them I don't even know if he is an agent
Joe does he I don't think he's an agent
he is an agent he has a manager he's got
[__] but I know he's like listen he's
your manager Jeff though is legit and
he's been with him since the beginning
you want to take a second and celebrate
a [__] that knows how to [__]
do it he signs two people Kevin James
and Joe Rogan I know what though that's
it [__] kids dude before
and by the way Rogan had to convince him
to sign Kevin James yeah he had to be
like trust me he gets nervous on stage
yeah he's gonna pay off yeah yeah he did
you signs two people back in the day
when he was like a waiter [__] day
and those are the two that he lives off
of
it and by the way let's just say shout
out I won't say anyone's business to
anyone but Joe Rogan takes care of the
people he works with oh yeah he's the
best he man he's the reason I tip the
way I tip I never tip like that that was
so stingy
no no like oh no like I'm saying like to
if I bought a drink five bucks yeah like
uh if I gotta if I got a car to the
airport uh yeah maybe 10 bucks but I was
I wasn't in that money yeah and then
Rogan one time and I say disrespectfully
I never want to speak for anyone